hello everybody and welcome to another
Python 3 basics video at this point
you've got all the basics necessary to
start employing modules we do still have
a few basics like classes and some other
stuff but now would be a good time I
think to talk about modules if you are
using Linux installing Python modules is
incredibly stupid easy so for
programming a lot of times Linux is way
easier than Windows but Windows is still
better I think for user friendliness I
suppose and other other applications but
that's not what this video is about when
it comes to installing programming in
Python module modules and all this Linux
is super easy and I believe Mac users
also have the same is basically the same
thing as Linux not basically but as far
as adding modules is concerned I think
they have their own little bash line and
everything but I'm not sure I've never
owned a Mac and never used Mac so so
yeah mainly with Windows the problem is
there's like there's a quite a few
methods for installation of modules and
nowadays there's really only one main
method but if you are looking around
online you're going to find everybody's
you know method and you've got you know
pip install setup tools download and
click and drag or set up the PI so at
the time of starting Python a large part
of my troubles was that I actually
couldn't like get a module right I
didn't understand like how do you do
this so I was obviously very frustrating
so first off python is going to look in
a few places for modules and those main
two places going to look is in site
packages so if you're on Windows that's
going to be C colon slash slash Python 3
3 or python 3 4 slash and then it's like
capital Li B and then inside packages I
think it's a list of directory so going
to look there it's also going to look in
the directory of your script so whatever
your script is in that directory you can
put stuff so say you're you know coming
from programming and java everybody in
Java likes you know each part of your
program has its own little file and at
the end you bring them all together and
so if you like to do that you can do
that in Python very simply and you just
leave each script in the directory and
you can import them
in the main scripts if you want it so
that's kind of how you can do it and I
think once you're familiar
familiarize yourself with the structure
of how to use modules all of this and
just understand how things work it'll
help you a lot certainly in the future
so enough on that though let's actually
install some stuff so I'm going to start
with Linux first just because it's super
easy uh-huh
so with Linux you're generally going to
see the following some super user do and
I'm going to use apt-get you can also if
you're if you use yum or whatever I'm
gonna use a pet and then we're going to
install and then usually what you're
going to have is Python - whatever the
module name is so in this case let's go
ahead and install matplotlib and that
should be it you hit enter and it will
start building dependencies and all that
and in a moment it will ask you if you
want to actually install it how much
space it's going to take and all of that
here is going to take 21 megabytes
that's okay why for yes enter and we're
on our way installing matplotlib and
that's it with Linux so it's obviously
very simple I'm not going to sit here
and wait until it's all done so I'm just
gonna move it aside for now and we're
going to start with installing things on
Windows so here we are with Windows if
you go on to for example we are on WWI
cutie graph org here and as we can see
here is the Downloads here they actually
give us not only the source they give us
if you're on Debian Ubuntu you can
download there and they even give us
Windows installers but most people I
found do not give you a Windows
installer and they certainly don't give
you 32 versus 64-bit so that can be
annoying mmm but anyway for the most
part everyone's going to have a tar.gz
otherwise referred to as a tarball so to
download it obviously will click it that
begins our download it's already done
let's show in folder here so here's our
download here so once you've downloaded
the tarball of whatever it is that you
are trying to install you're going to
need to somehow decompress it if you're
on Windows a good free decompress or a
7-zip I like 7-zip you can also use
WinZip
if you have it and you've got that
working for you anyway 7-zip we're just
going to extract here and when you do
that you'll have a dist folder a
distributed folder go ahead and click on
that and you've got another tar file
once again 7-zip extract here find a
problem and here we've got PI QT graph -
in the file version and within that you
have a setup file now you can't just
click setup that's not going to work out
for you what you're going to need to do
is install it so I needs a little trick
that one of my viewers actually told me
is you can hold down shift right click
of the folder and you come down here and
you can open it in a process I don't
think that's what I want I want to open
it in command I think
let's try process see if that works no
that's not what we wanted maybe I'm just
missing it or something
there we go command wind down ok
so opening command window here and
basically that's gonna take you to the
location so you don't actually have to
type it all out so once you're there
I've been using Linux too much I can't
even tell you what we can do to get
anyway we're in this file and instead of
that pi is what we want so to call setup
hi
you just have to do set up to PI install
now if you've coming from any of my
other videos usually what I would type
is Python setup to PI install but if you
want to use Python you're gonna have to
have Python added to your path and
generally you probably already do but if
you didn't it would give you problems
but actually I was just reading the
documents and you don't have to say
python setup i install you just have to
say setup to pi install so you hit enter
and that will install the package for
you now python QT graph or pie cutie
graph won't actually work unless you
have scifi and some other dependency
installed i just want to show you guys
an example of the installation process
now the last thing I'm going to show you
guys is again on pie cutie graph org
they came with a fancy Windows installer
nice but a lot of modules will not do
this for you also they might not work
like they might only have a 32-bit
installer but not a 64 and you've got a
you know build your own so obviously
that's pretty problematic for a lot of
people and but luckily there is a
website that has some great windows
instead of installers for things that
typically don't have installers or again
don't come in like 64-bit for example
and that website is this website here if
I recall I'll put it in the description
otherwise if I forget someone remind me
and I'll make sure it gets in the
description anyway it's just got a whole
bunch of modules here so you can
actually download them and as you can
see they come in for Python 2 6 all the
way up to 3 4 and they come in both
64-bit and 32-bit so it's a huge help
this website and it just takes a lot of
that hassle out of downloading and then
if you have to rebuild you won't have to
hear some time over that helped some of
you guys out as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions until next time